Transcriber: Alaa ElMoshneb
المدقّق: Mujtaba bakhet
مرحبا بكم كيف حالكم
انا اسمي اسيا عمري عشرة سنوات
اليوم سأتحدث عن
أو اسمحوا لي أن أبدأ بهذه الطريقة
هل تم التنمر عليك من قبل ؟
أو هل تعتقد أن طفلك يتعرض للتنمر؟
لذلك، هذا الموضوع هو فقط لأجلك
ما التنمر ؟
التنمر هو شكل من أشكال السلوك العدواني
من طفل أو أكثر على طفل آخر
سواء لفظيا أو جسديا
وهذا هو التعريف الأكاديمي المكتوب في جميع
الكتب والمواقع الإلكترونية
اسمحوا لي أن أشرح التعريف الذي أفهمه
التنمر هو الشعور بالغضب والعجز والحزن
الذي تشعر به عندما يسخر منك شخص ما
في شيء لا يمكنك تغييره
ليس خطأك أن لديك شعر مجعد
لديك بشرة داكنة
طويل ام قصير
قلبك ينكسر
عندما لا تستطيع الدفاع عن نفسك
من المتنمرين
أعتقد أن هذا هو أفضل تعريف للتنمر
عندما تشعر كل يوم أنك فقدت الثقة في نفسك
لم يعد بإمكانك التمييز بين
المزاح والتنمر بعد الآن
عندما تكره النظر في المرآة أو
تكره نفسك بالفعل
أعتقد أن هذا أقل ما يمكن أن يشعر
به الشخص المتنمر عليه
أو كما يسمونها
“التأثير السلبي للتنمر”
هل سمع أحد عن كوستا؟
لا لا لا أقصد المقهى المعروف
الذي يقدم الكابتشينو
أنا أتحدث عن شخص
والذي للأسف لم ينالوا الاحترام والتقدير
كما يستحق كل إنسان
ونتيجة لذلك تم اعتباره مثالاً لآثار
التنمر الوحشي
من هو كوستا ؟
كوستا مراهق يبلغ من العمر 13 عامًا
الذي يعيش في صربيا
وكان يتعرض للتنمر من قبل أصدقائه ومدرسيه
لأنه كان انطوائيا، لا يتكلم، ولم يكن ذكيا
لذلك تم وضعه في اللجوء
هل يمكنك أن تتخيل مدى سوء التنمر؟
ولهذا يجب أن يكون لنا دور في
حل هذه المشكلة
لن نجلس مكتوفي الأيدي عندما يتعلق
الأمر بالتنمر
لأن أي مساعدة نقدمها الآن ستنقذنا من
مشاكل كثيرة في المستقبل
علم أطفالك أن يطلبوا المساعدة
عند  مواجهة المتنمرين
طلب المساعدة ليس ضعفا
ماذا لو لم يجدوا المساعدة اللازمة
علموا أطفالكم أن يثقوا بأنفسهم
ورسالتي إلى أي متنمر
أنت ضعيف
عليك أن تفهم سبب ضعفك
أنت لست مضحكا
أنت لست مرحا” على الإطلاق
وأنت لست مهرج
قد يقول بعض الناس أنكي
لا تقدمي أي حلول
نعم لدي حلول
وهي 3 حلول
أولاً يجب على المتنمر أن يعتذر
للشخص الذي تنمر عليه
أو الابتعاد عن الشخص الذي ساعده في التنمر
ثالثاً: عليه أن يحاول إيقاف التنمر
بشكل كامل
.شكرًا لكم